[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur france 3 en
bourgogne franche comté pour cette
émission spéciale au lendemain de ce
second tour de l'élection des élections
législatives
comment ont voté les électeurs en région
et comment les politiques s'organisent
pour cette nouvelle mandature qui débute
alors tout d'abord le rapport de force
avec les différents députés de notre
grande région que vous voyez on précise
qu'il ya deux pour le ps puisque
frédéric barbier dans le doubs avait la
double étiquette ps la république en
marche on y reviendra avec lui dans
cette émission on analysera cette
situation politique nouvelle avec
catherine ngiri et lilian melet bien sûr
et puis place aux débats
dans cette émission avec celles et ceux
qui ont accepté cet exercice aujourd'hui
en direct et uniquement des
personnalités élus ou réélus
hier soir didier martin d'abord de la
république en marche
élu député de la première
circonscription de côte-d'or jean marie
sermier pour les républicains réélu
député de la 3e circonscription du jura
didier parisse de la république en
marche élu député de la 5e
circonscription de côte-d'or est avec
nous en direct de mâcon cécile
untermaier du parti socialiste réélu
député de la 4e circonscription de saône
et loire est avec nous en direct de
montbéliard yanbu car élu député les
républicains de la première
circonscription du territoire de belfort
merci à tous d'avoir accepté d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui d'autres invités nous
rejoindrons bien sûr dans le cours de
cette émission
avant de vous donner la parole pour
débattre des résultats mais aussi
peut-être et surtout de la suite de ce
qui va suivre à l'assemblée nationale un
coup d'oeil sur certains nouveaux
visages d'un élément fort de la soirée
que nous avons vécu ensemble sur france
3 hier comme par exemple celui de
yolaine de courson dans la 4e
circonscription de côte-d'or au nord du
département jusqu alors maire de la
commune d'avant près de montbard elle a
battu charles barrière le candidat l
érudit la soirée d'une nouvelle élue
avec amélie doué et isabelle rivière
tout à l'air tout à fait 17 heures
violaine de course on abandonne sa
mairie à ses adjoints maire d'une
commune de 73 habitants il lui est
difficile de prendre la température sur
place
en route pour la préfecture de dijon la
tension monte
les premiers résultats commencent à
tomber c'est serré très serré dans le
châtillonnais il semblerait que du côté
de sainte colombe et où je s'entête à
châtillon les records 300 voix de retard
il s'en va voir ses global qui va
compter en chemin elle ne résiste pas à
vérifier par elle-même
ce sera ma lin une commune de 750
habitants déjà conséquent dans cette
circonscription rurale
il ya une grande différence qui a pas
autant par ailleurs le blanc bravo balle
a alors j'en ai pas de chez super dense
mais j'ai pas les villes ça s'est
vraiment passé quoi ou je risque
c'est-à-dire chez lui à pas les grosses
villes voilà mais en chemin
tout s'accélère c'est génial on va à la
rumeur se confirme le maire de châtillon
n'a finalement pas appelé à voter pour
le candidat de la droite ça s'envoie
d'avant sa fatigue
c'est donc presque sereinement que
yolaine de course ont rejoint son
suppléant préfecture finalement la
candidate en marche l'emportent avec
51,29 % des suffrages
725 voilà sépare de charles barrière une
victoire serrée mais largement
suffisante pour les militants qui
attendent impatiemment leur candidate à
montbard autre nouvelle figure de notre
grande région fanette charvier toujours
pour la république en mars sortie
vainqueur hier d'un duel de dames dans
la première circonscription du doubs
elle s'est emparée du siège de la
socialiste frondeuse barbara romagnan
emmanuel rivals un jean-marie baverel
19h la candidate de la république en
marche arrive sur la pointe des pieds
fanette chervier n'en est pas sûr mais
elle vient de battre la députée sortante
barbara romagnan j'ai quelques résultats
mais c'est vraiment pas à représentatif
c'est certes quelques quelques bureaux
de vote qui remonte au fur et à mesure
donc pour l'instant je préfère attendre
les résultats définitifs pour commenter
les résultats lui sont favorables aux
périphéries beaucoup moins sur besançon
pendant quelques minutes les 14 points
d'avance du premier tour semble loin
finalement c'est chez nos confrères de
france bleu qu'elle a la confirmation de
sa victoire c'est définitif c'est
officiel c'est la première élection en
tant que député de fanette charvier avec
un score de 53 49 % devant par parrot
magnan c'est un résultat effectivement
sérémé mais voilà c'est tout cas c'est
c'est tout de même la légitimité des
urnes qui parle de ce soir barbara
romagnan avait prévenu ce deuxième tour
devait remettre les compteurs à zéro
elle qui avait finalement obtenu le
soutien de jean luc mélenchon dans
l'entre-deux-tours échoue en larmes
après un seul mandat
je suis déçu évidemment pour ceux qui
sont là qui qui sont beaucoup beaucoup
mobilisé
je remercie beaucoup et puis voilà je
suis inquiète de ce qui se passe
j'espère que tous les députés qui sont
là qui sont bien des députés autonome la
loi qui sera un travail qui se prépare
vraiment très inquiétant fanette
chervier poids plume de la politique
parfaitement inconnus des électeurs il
ya quelques semaines encore devient à 32
ans la plus jeune député du doubs
exemple de renouvellement alors lilian
melet la bourgogne notamment est marquée
par un très fort renouvellement avec 10
nouveaux députés de la république en
marche
oui incontestablement en bourgogne cette
victoire de la république en marche
renouvelle profondément le paysage
politique alors que d'habitude on ne se
hissait à l'assemblée qu'après avoir
gravi les échelons dans les
collectivités parce qu'il y a des
nouveaux complet avec en figure de proue
les nivernais perrine goulet patrice
perron aucun mandat jusque là dans ce
cas aussi
yolaine de courson convient de voir en
côte d'or elle est maire d'une petite
commune
benjamin dirks et raphaël gauvin en
saône et loire mais il ya aussi des gens
d'expérience sous l'étiquette en marche
didier martin à dijon qui est sur notre
plateau a été conseiller régional
rémy rebeyrotte maire d'autun et dans le
circuit depuis un certain temps michel
crouzet dans l'yonne et conseillère
départementale pour la majorité de
droite soit dit en passant par leur
régler ça et didier parisse à beaune
ancien sous préfet était directeur des
services de la région
on peut dire qu'il connaît la musique
mais il n'a jamais été élu
jusque là merci willian pour ses
premiers éléments d'analysé
contrairement donc à ce qu'on pouvait
penser à l'issue du premier tour il ya
des poches de résistance à cette fameuse
vague en marche
exemple dans le jura deux députés
sortants aient l'air sauvent leur siège
le maire de dole jean marie sermier qui
est avec nous et qu'on entendra dans un
instant et puis marie christine dalloz
loyer pour elle la victoire est encore
plus savoureuse au vu des résultats du
premier tour qu'il ne la plaçait pas
favoris florence petit david martin
franchement j'imaginais pas ça
la candidate l'est républicain vient
d'apprendre qu'elle est réélu avec un
peu plus de 57 % des voix
pour marie christine dalloz de ses trois
victoires législatives
c'est de loin la plus belle j'ai
toujours douté parce que je savais que
c'était difficile parce que je voyais
une vague nationale qui qui reprit qui
s'apparente son ami tellement il y avait
et résister à ça c'est ma proximité mon
travail moment la reconnaissance de mon
investissement auprès des eaux
jurassienne d'aidé aux jurassiens de son
côté la candidate la république en
marche avait pu espérer elle aussi la
victoire au premier tour moins de deux
points seulement la séparait de son
adversaire
de toute évidence mon électorat ne s'est
pas déplacé pour le second tour les
reports de voix qu'il était prévu ne se
sont pas faits probablement parce que
ils ont estimé que en marche avait une
trop grande majorité au niveau national
et qu'il voulait peut-être freiné les
choses
le front national s'est massivement
reportés sur madame dalloz ils se sont
mobilisés ils se sont déplacés pour
aller voter pour une candidate qui
incarne la droite dure la droite
fillonniste conservatrice et ils lui ont
donné la victoire
avec ce résultat sans appel la
circonscription de saint claude confirme
donc son ancrage à droite on a vu les
résistances 4e série la franche comté
étaient majoritairement à droite jusqu'à
maintenant est ce qu'elle a perdu la
droite beaucoup de terreur bien dans la
grande question qu'on se posait hier
soir avant les résultats
c'était est ce que la droite va résister
bien la réponse est oui la droite à
résister en franche comté
déjà les quatre députés aient l'air
sortants sont réélus
annie genevard dans le haut doubs
jean-marie sermier et marie-christine
dalons vient de voix dans le jura michel
keller dans le territoire de belfort et
puis toujours dans le territoire de
belfort à un nouvel élu yann bout car il
les réussit à garder dans le camp des
républicains la circonscription de
damien meslot qui ne se représentait pas
alors dans la précédente mandature la
droite détenait 8 circonscriptions sur
12 en franche comté
suite au scrutin d'hier elle en garde
tout de même 5 leur symbole de ce qui
s'est passé à gauche c'est la défaite de
l'aide députés socialistes barbara
romagnan la frondeuse qui a été battu
par la candidate de la république en
marche fanette charlier qui était
inconnu il ya encore six semaines
donc vous voyez donc 53 5% pour fans et
charvier elle rmc le grand parti gagnant
en franche comté il détient maintenant
sept circonscriptions sur les douze ont
été réélus eric alauzet l'écologiste
frédéric barbier qui avaient la double
investiture
lrm et ps et puis les nouveaux députés
lrm outre fanette charvier s'appelle
denis sommaire dans le pays de
montbéliard
danielle brulebois dans le jura barbara
baisse au balo et christophe lejeune en
haute saône
ils ont tous les deux ces deux derniers
nous gagner les duels qui les opposait
au front national
merci catherine alors jean marie sermier
on va vous donner la parole vous faites
partie des résistants est-ce que c'est
comme ça que vous voyez les choses
aujourd'hui vous faites partie des
détonnant de droite en franche comté qui
ont réussi le pari de résister à cette
fameuse vague en marche
oui enfin l'objectif est pas de résister
à quelque chose objectif est surtout de
pouvoir construire et comme on l'a dit
pendant la campagne électorale en ce qui
me concerne moi j'étudierai les textes
législatifs les uns après les autres et
en fonction
de l'intérêt pour notre pays en fonction
de l'intérêt pour le territoire et pour
ses habitants
je crois que au delà de la résistance
est ce que vous avez eu peur entre les
deux tours quand vous avez vu des
résultats du premier tour peur pour vous
porte pour marie-christine dalo bah
écoutez moi j'étais en tête de six
points sur le premier tour donc on a
mobilisé quand même l'électorat alors
que d'habitude un rappelant en rappelant
que c'est important d'aller voter pour
pour soutenir les candidats c'est moins
facile que d'habitude c'est de la
circonscription la troisième
circonscription du jura n'a jamais été
une circonscription extrêmement facile
de voir elle était nettement dans
l'abstention et puis peut-être aussi le
nom d'un certain nombre de d'électeurs
qui ont voté en marche au premier tour
mais qui ont bien compris qu'ils
auraient une majorité présidentielle
très forte et qui se sont dit ben voilà
notre député sortant il a fait du boulot
il n'est pas contre de tendre la main et
donc on revient vers lui tendre la main
ça veut dire quoi peut-être à venir
étudier les textes des uns après les
autres en fonction de l'intérêt des
français
quand vous voyez jean marie sermier
facilement réélu dans les
circonscriptions ça veut dire quoi
didier pas risque là le tsunami qu'on
annonçait finalement a pas eu lieu et
qu'en fonction de la spécificité des
circonscriptions il ya des gens qui qui
ont résisté à ces deux vagues en marche
oui oui évidemment une amie moi je c'est
difficile de parler de cheney mais en
plus épais mais on a vu une vague de
fond elle a été puissante aux élections
présidentielles elle était assez
puissante aussi au premier tour des
élections législatives après que le
corps électoral veille peut y trouver
elle a fait peur à des électeurs qui
sont dit s'être grosse avec une majorité
trop fort d'être peut-être sans doute
cette partie là puisque dit aussi
monsieur servier est pas inexact ça
s'applique un peu partout c'est à dire
qu' une partie de l'électorat qui a
conservé que les choses étaient acquises
est tout simplement une moindre
mobilisation ça c est moi l'analyse que
j'ai en tout cas sur la 5e
circonscription c'est que c'est assez
clairement une forme de remobilisation
d'un électorat classique
qui est un électorat de droite dans une
circonscription qui était une
circonscription classique - droite donc
c'est pas totalement anormal qu'un
certain nombre d'électeurs va y revenir
à ce fondamental là il n'empêche que moi
j'avais treize points avance au premier
tour 7 5 points d'avancé au deuxième
tour voilà le geste de l'électeur et six
dixièmes et à l'idée martin est ce que
c'est le premier avertissement des
électeurs pour la république en marche
cette 2000 vague finalement si j'ose
dire écoutez moi je pense que les
électeurs ils savaient ce qu'ils
voulaient et finalement tous les
candidats la république en marche
ils ont fait le plein au premier tour
ils ont un peu augmenté leur score au
deuxième tour
donc ceux qui sont originaires d'autres
familles politiques qui voulaient être
fidèles à leur famille politique soit la
droite ou la gauche sont retournés
naturellement vers leurs familles la
république en marche
elle trace sa voie elle a fait le plein
au premier tour elle amplifie son score
au deuxième tour c'est ça qui est
important
l'un a parlé dans les deux cas de duel
entre en marche et la droite vous aviez
une spécificité la première de côte-d'or
c'est celle qui est liée à la ville de
dijon aussi vous avez d'abord affronter
le ps avant d'affronter la droite au
deuxième tour et ça a été un duel on va
dire difficiles très tendues
il y avait dix sept candidats sur cette
première circonscription de côte-d'or je
n'ai pas affronter le parti socialiste
j'aime terre en compétition avec tous
les autres la droite était divisé il
faut le reconnaître
le front national dans le département de
la côte d'or a appelé à faire barrage à
la république en marche
mais malgré cela la république en marche
résiste et fait le bon score qui lui
permet de placer quatre députés sur cinq
en côte d'or allez parler des résistants
de droite on peut parler aussi des
survivants de gauche avec cécile
untermaier du parti socialiste réélu
député dans la 4e circonscription de
saône-et-loire bonjour alors est ce que
vous vous considérez comme une miraculée
aujourd'hui j'irai je n'irai peut-être
pas jusque là
c'est vrai que le premier tour a été
difficile mais j'étais donc qualifié
pour le second tour avec une droite
divisée
certes mais aussi une gauche divisée
puisque nous avions la france insoumise
et puis d'être qualifiés au second tour
avoir plus que deux candidatures
finalement le paysage c'est clair et on
voit mieux finalement les profils je
pense que le mien avec un un bilan avec
la volonté
d'éviter tout sectarisme que j'avais
démontré sur le territoire pendant cinq
ans et puis le souci finalement d'une de
gens de territoire de campagne qui se
laisse moi emporter par des effets de
mode et plus par la réalité des choses a
sans doute joué puisque je loue jours
meilleurs on précise quand même que
j'avais six points de retard au premier
tour et qu'en arrivant j'arrive avec 10
points supplémentaires en étant en tête
dans toutes les communes quasiment c'est
ils ont tous ces noms comme ailleurs est
ce qu'on peut dire que on va dire vous
n'avez pas exagérer avec l'étiquette ps
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire pour
laver un petit peu perdu en route et que
sur certains points vous n'étiez pas
opposés non plus à la majorité des
manuels macron pas sur tous les points
mais sur un certain nombre de points
on peut dire que vous avez essayé de
jouer là dessus dans cette campagne bape
a pas tant que ça parce que finalement
moi j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec
emmanuel macron je le connais et c'est
vrai qu'en face
j'ai eu une candidature modem qui est
tombé un peu au dernier moment et qui à
mon sens au second tour a montrée
peut-être une crédibilité moindre que
celle que moi je pouvait incarner dans
un travail constructif à l'assemblée
nationale que j'ai déjà mené pendant
cinq ans et que j'ai bien l'intention de
poursuivre dans les cinq ans qui
viennent
madame j'aimerais vous poser une
question concernant l'avenir du parti
socialiste on a appris par exemple ce
matin que jean louis fousseret le maire
socialiste de besançon et qui avait
rejoint emmanuel macron quitte le parti
socialiste il y à vraiment au parti
c'est beaucoup de gens qui sont partis
ou qui vont encore partir comment vous
le voyez ce que vous vous voyez votre
avenir au parti socialiste
et comment vous voyez l'avenir du parti
socialiste écoutez moi je vous propose
de me réinviter pour qu'on en parle
est ce que c'est un petit peu tôt tout
ça et je vais aller à l'assemblée
nationale demain j'ai demandé à ce que
on rencontre quand même les collègues
puisque nous sommes en 40 46
on compte les divers gauche le prg et
c'est là qu'on se rencontre et qu'on
parle de tout ça parce que c'est vrai
que c'est une vrai que c'est une vraie
question est l'avenir du parti
socialiste en tout cas je pense qu'il
est de toute façon des gens dont les
dents les valeurs précède le parti et
lui survive
donc c'est plutôt à eux et moins parties
de travailler à une réflexion comment on
peut être utile au pays et à nos
circonscriptions avec les valeurs
auxquelles nous sommes très attachés
je pense que c'est une belle question
n'est ce pas et avant de vous inviter
pour parler du ps une question beaucoup
plus pragmatique est ce que vous aller
siéger dans le groupe ps à l'assemblée a
écouté
c'est ce que je vous disais réinviter
moi et je vous le dirai c'est dans
quelques jours va vous pouvez le dire
quand même c'est dans quelques jours
mais il ya une précipitation vous savez
j'ai même pas rencontré mes collègues
j'ai même pas pu échanger un mot avec
les collègues avec qui j'ai gg j'ai
travaillé pendant cinq ans on a des gens
très intéressants qui ont été réélus je
suis très contente d'apprendre la
réélection des candidats socialistes je
suis très déçu effectivement de la delà
de la défaite de certains qui auraient
été extrêmement utiles dans le
territoire dans le territoire de saône
et loire
mais on en est là il faut savoir dans
quel état d'esprit ils sont par rapport
à la confiance au gouvernement voyez je
sais pas si simple que ça même s'il faut
qu'on réfléchisse qu'on travaille on a
nos valeurs de gauche on veut les
défendre mais je vous dis je vous
donnerai pas de réponse aujourd'hui on
va vous réalité dans quelques jours pas
d'inquiétude c'est si long terme
ailleurs merci d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui
yanbu car lui est élu député les
républicains dans la première
circonscription du territoire de belfort
on le retrouve depuis notre studio de
montbéliard yanbu car vous avez sauvé la
circonscription de votre mentor de
monsieur meslot le maire de belfort et
ça n'était pas gagné d'avancé on vous
imagine très satisfait oui je suis
extrêmement satisfait parce que dimanche
dernier j'avais dit à votre antenne que
rien n'était perdu qu'on avait certes
beaucoup de retard mais qu'on allait
mobiliser le plus possible pour essayer
de rattraper ce retard
on a travaillé toute la semaine 24
heures sur 24 pour mobiliser les
abstentionnistes les jeunes
famille politique qui n'avait pas été
voté au premier tour et aussi c'est de
convaincre les électeurs qui n'avaient
pas qu'ils n'avaient pas voté pour nos
premiers tours de nous rejoindre pour
faire en sorte que nous puissions
conserver ce siège
est ce que il ya une bluecar est ce que
c'est le système damien meslot qui a
fonctionné
on le sait très très puissante dans le
département du territoire de belfort
je crois que c'est surtout le travail de
damien meslot qui a fonctionné parce
qu'aujourd'hui si je suis élu député
c'est parce que je me suis inscrit dans
la continuité du travail qu'il avait
fait depuis 15 ans du travail de fond de
proximité auprès des électeurs auprès
des associations auprès des élus locaux
pour faire en sorte que notre que notre
territoire soit bien représenté à
l'assemblée nationale est ce que vous
craignez le recours de christophe
grudler votre adversaire les recours
qu'il va déposer devant la justice peut
bien déposer de recours le recours
qu'ils veulent les électeurs ont tranché
hier soir et je suis absolument serein
alors comment vous voyez vous voyez
votre opposition à l'assemblée nationale
jean marie sermier autres députés et
l'eire qui lui un petit peu plus de
bouteille que vous sans jeu de mot
disait qu'il allait voter certains
textes qui lui conviendrait vous c'est
une opposition franche massive ou c'est
aussi la main tendue n'a absolument pas
j'aurai je n'aurai absolument pas dit
mieux que jean marie sermier
effectivement c'est ce que j'ai dit
pendant ma campagne ni opposition
systématique parce que je pense que
c'est un système qui a vécu et dont les
citoyens ne veulent plus nous
approbation automatique non plus parce
qu'il y aura des textes proposés par la
république en marché qui ne nous
conviendront pas pour la france et pour
le territoire de belfort
car est-ce que vous allez être un des
plus jeunes députés à l ère de la
nouvelle assemblée pourrait vous cachez
vos collègues m'ont dit que j'étais le
plus jeune j'ai pas vérifié mais je
crois qu'il n'y a que deux députés qui
seront plus jeune que moi de de la
république en marche vers troisième donc
plus jeunes si j'ose dire merci d'avoir
été en direct avec nous depuis
montbéliard est ce que vous êtes donc
élu et député du territoire de belfort
un tout petit mot je reviens petit peu
en arrière pour signaler quand même
qu'il ya que deux députés socialistes
qui reste en bourgogne franche comté et
que cécile untermaier que l'héritière
d'arnaud montebourg sur sa
circonscription
on n'a pas réussi à lui faire dire
vraiment elle va siéger avec le groupe
socialiste à l'assemblée trois qu'il
faut quand même remarquer qu' on va
avoir tout à l'heure frédéric bardoux
voilà la double investiture pc la
république en marche pour le parti
socialiste mais c'est ce que vous
faisiez alors elle est très claire
donc le groupe ait l'air se formera on a
aujourd'hui plus de 113 députés si j'ai
bien compris et autant nous sommes
favorables à la main tendue autant nous
sommes favorables à étudier tous les
textes on parle enfin aujourd'hui sur un
groupe qui est extrêmement déterminé
mais il est quand même possible qu'ils
aient un autre groupe de nom a comparé à
l intérieur de l air un groupe
passerelle un groupe jean pierre
raffarin alain juppé tous ces gens là
ont évoqué sa non non je crois surtout
qu'il ya un groupe et les airs alors les
rully et puis alors qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes unis et que par rapport à ce
qu'on nous annonçait il ya moins d'une
semaine
eh bien on est là on est présent plus
déjantée groupe de droite et être plus
proche du pouvoir c'est ça vous vous
ennuieriez quoi vous le 6 janvier
raffarin il pousse un groupe qui va le
problème n'est pas d'avoir un groupe
supplémentaire créerait le problème
c'est d'étudier les textes et puis de
les étudier en fonction de normes de
l'intérieur lundi à l'intérieur des
républiques oreille au règlement numéro
citoyens ce qu'ils apportent envoyé une
facture on parle de fracture aujourd'hui
une des factures essentiel dans notre
civilisation et de notre société c'est
la fracture territoriale et il me semble
qu'il serait intéressant j'aime bien le
savoir pour pas répondu à ma question
qu'on puisse avoir une année très très
puissant avoir une réponse très précise
de la porte du gouvernement sur la
fracture territoriale et sur l'avenir de
la ruralité de 80% sur l ai pas fait
sourire les députés de la république en
marche qui sont en face de vous jean
marie sermier un commentaire parce que
vous
un groupe de droite qui passeraient
voilà freitas rires j'aimerais surtout
qu'on apporte une réponse rapide la
commande beaucoup ces résultats c'est
normal on est le lendemain d'élections
journée donc votre expertise se fait
sentir et vous êtes des observateurs
très attentive de la vie politique
mais les français n'attendent pas cela
en fait et peu leur importe si la droite
sera divisée ou pas diviser sachy les
choses l'opposition sera moins massive
vous pouvez pas le nier alors vous êtes
à nouveau député
mais vous imaginez bien comment ça se
passe dans l'hémicycle et en commission
la république en marche aura la majorité
absolue à l'assemblée
donc nous devons nous mettre d'accord
absolument on écoutera leurs amendements
ou non on écoutera on écoutera leurs
propositions je le maintiens on leur
amendement s'ils sont utiles seront
certainement étudié acceptés ils
présideront la commission des finances
comme c'est la tradition
et puis à partir de là il faut répondre
aux questions que se posent les français
sur la formation sur la formation
professionnelle
c'est ça qu'ils attendent et des
réponses rapides répandit comme didier
martin on est on est plutôt spectateur
de la reconstruction politique des
groupes que ce soit le ps vous l'avez
évoqué où que ce soit les républicains
prix nous sommes premiers ministres de
droit qui va venir devant l'assemblée où
vous serez majoritaire il me semble
qu'il ya un socle fondamental et 350
députation si on inclut évidemment le
modem et c'est tout à fait une logique
ce que nous souhaiterions éviter c'est
qu'au sein de notre groupe ce soit ce
soit
comment dit on a une majorité absolue
nous avons une responsabilité absolue et
séoul point central c'est à dire que
nous voulons absolument que le programme
qui a été présenté aux français qui a
été validé par les français par emmanuel
macron son gouvernement et les candidats
que nous étions devenus députés depuis
effectivement quelques heures seulement
donc nous souhaitons que les choses
soient clairement position à table aux
autres partis politiques unis ou des
unis à la limite ce n'est pas notre
problème n'est unis ou désuni de ceux de
se fixer par rapport à ce programme
c'est la ligne après ou sens très bien
qu il y aura d adhésion à la carte
adhésion volontaire pas volontaire à des
sous et on nous mais je reprends ce qu'a
dit mon collègue et ami ce que nous
souhaitons c'est tout simplement que que
nous puissions nous retrouver sur et
textes fondamentaux on a là dès
maintenant des textes de reconstruction
économique et 2 et de protection sociale
à mettre en oeuvre sans attendre donc
que les uns et les autres attendent pour
voir dans quelles conditions politiques
qui vont se constituer c'est une chose
c'est pas vraiment le problème du jour
alors il y en a un qui sait sur dix y
apparaissent ne sera pas dans votre camp
dans quelques jours mise en danger après
le premier tour guillaume larrivé est
passé à l'offensive alors sur notre
antenne il avait qualifié son adversaire
d'inutiles de godillots une campagne
très dure couronnée de succès dans
l'yonne
johan albrecht quand un sésame
guillaume larrivé savoure sa victoire
pour la deuxième fois il remporte la
1ère circonscription de bonnes avec
52,59 % des suffrages
1800 voix d'avancé principalement issus
des zones rurales de la circonscription
j'étais venu en 2012 malgré la vague
rose
monsieur hollande je suis réélue en 2017
malgré ce tsunami
macro nist y voit la démonstration de la
confiance est de la fidélité qui m'est
donnée par une majorité des habitants de
notre territoire de l'yonne les
républicains remportent deux des trois
circonscriptions du département grâce à
un excellent report de voix en
ballottage défavorable à l'issue du
premier tour guillaume larrivé à
rattraper plus de 4 points et demi de
retard à la plus grande joie de ses
supporters heureux enfin on attendait le
mérite guillaume c'est à laurent du
canton de poche depuis dix ans participe
vraiment actuellement auprès de
guillaume et là c'est vrai que c'était
pas gagné mais on a gagné porte-à-porte
courrier aux habitants dans chaque
village ses équipes se sont fortement
mobilisés pendant l'entre-deux-tours
plus que ravi nous l'avons soutenu
soutenu énormément et aujourd'hui on est
ravi d'avoir une super me réussit
l'abstention plus élevé qu'au premier
tour a également joué en faveur du
candidat républicain qui remporte ainsi
une victoire plus nette qu'en 2012
voilà pour la soirée de guillaume
larrivé réélu député les républicains
dans l'yonne
autre élu du côté des républicains ces
josiane corneloup qu'on retrouve depuis
notre studio de mâcon bonjour vous êtes
donc élue députée les républicains dans
la 2e circonscription de saône et loire
c'est le charolais-brionnais merci
d'être avec nous vous avez peut-être
entendu notre débat avec jean marie
sermier il ya un instant comment est ce
que vous allez vous situez vous dans
cette nouvelle assemblée
bonjour à tous et bien écoutez moi je
suis tout à fait heureuse d'avoir
remporté la victoire hier soir qui était
une victoire qui n'était pas forcément
acquise puisque nous avons bien vu qu'à
l'issue du premier tour
et bien il y avait sept points d'écart
entre entre nous donc j'étais ravi de
voir que les électrices et électeurs de
cette circonscription en
reporté leurs voix sur ma candidature
certainement au regard de mon
implication sur ce territoire du fait
que je sois né j'ai grandi dans cette
circonscription est que je sois élu
depuis un certain nombre d'années ça
c'est votre élection ce grand territoire
mais on est déjà dans l'après second
tour comment allez vous gérer
aujourd'hui votre présence à l'assemblée
nationale avec les pros les projets de
loi de la majorité présidentielle et
comment allez vous vous situez au sein
de l'hémicycle
mais vous savez je les dis pendant la
campagne
je crois qu'aujourd'hui l'électorat ne
souhaite plus la division systématique
l'opposition systématique et j'ai dit
que je ne serais pas dans une opposition
systématique que je souhaitais avoir une
attitude constructive responsable et
j'étudierai donc les textes législatifs
et je veux très favorablement ce qui me
paraissent être tout à fait en accord
avec l'intérêt général et avec l'intérêt
de nos concitoyens
josaine comme le loup est ce que c'est
ce que vous avez dit aux gens que vous
avez rencontrées dans cet entre deux
tours
est-ce que de votre point de vue c'est
ça qui fonctionnait aussi c'est à dire
que certain nombre d'électeurs et
d'électeurs de droite voulait députés de
droite mais il voulait pas quelqu'un
dans l'opposition systématique vous
pensez que c'est ça qui a marché ou
c'est d'autres ressorts qui ont
fonctionné
je pense qu'il y à un ensemble de choses
qui ont qui sont entrés en jeu
certainement le fait que je sois de ce
territoire puisque en face de moi
vincent chauvet était quelqu'un qui
n'était encore pas connu sur ce
territoire il ya trois mois
le fait que je me sois investi moi même
sur ce territoire depuis de nombreuses
années pour la réalisation de projets
structurants et puis peut-être
effectivement comme vous le dites
le fait que j'ai dit très clairement que
je ne serai pas dans une opposition
systématique
je crois que ça correspond vraiment un
souhait de nos concitoyens aujourd'hui
tout à leur projet notre notre pays a
besoin de réformes profondes qui doivent
être engagés rapidement et c'était
quelque chose qui était souhaité tout à
l'heure jean marie sermier n'a pas voulu
répondre à ma question mais comment vous
voyez le
aps les républicains à l'assemblée
nationale est ce qu'il y aura un groupe
et plus peut-être un sous groupe qui
pourrait travailler avec emmanuel macron
et sa majorité
autrement dit est-ce que les
républicains vous allez rester toujours
un groupe homogène où il ya de telles
différences entre les uns et les autres
que vous allez être forcément obligé de
scinder les choses alors écoutez moi je
n'ai c'est mon premier mandat législatif
donc je n'ai pas l'antériorité donc dans
un premier temps nous sommes conviés
pour nous rencontrer et je pense que
ceci est nécessaire j'apprécierais à ce
moment les différents courants et nous
verrons bien je crois qu'il est
important aujourd'hui que les
républicains lui d y restent unis merci
beaucoup pour ses premières réactions on
va rejoindre notre studio de montbéliard
où on retrouve frédéric barbier
réélu député de la 4e circonscription du
doubs alors on le dit depuis le début de
cette campagne frédéric barbier avec la
double étiquette ps la république en
marche d'ailleurs c'est compliqué on au
graphique qu'on essaye de vous montrer
on sait plus trop vous caser au final
frédéric barbier vous serez ou au final
je vais siéger avec la république en
marche mais en même temps c'est je veux
dire la république en mars a vocation à
réunir des hommes des femmes de gauche
du centre de droite de différentes
sensibilités politiques moi je suis un
social démocrate de gouvernement et je
pense que les français en ont soupé de
ces combats de ces ce combat stérile qui
n'aboutissent strictement à rien il nous
demande de travailler ensemble
j'y suis j'y suis prêt alors la double
appartenance pendant une campagne
électorale c'est une chose la double
appartenance après c'en est une autre
donc est-ce que vous allez quitter le
parti socialiste pour cij est en marche
jean louis fousseret a annoncé ce matin
qu'il quittait le parti socialiste alors
vous qu'est ce que vous allez faire
écoutez moi je les vis depuis le départ
je suis socialiste et on verra ce que
décidera le parti socialiste
personnellement je souhaite bien dit
qu'elle pensait ce vous exclus en fait
c'est ça vous voulez pas prendre la
décision vous même
je n'attends pas que le psg
catherine même exclu que je souhaite
travailler aussi à une forme de
reconstruction je pense que le parti
socialiste a besoin de se reconstruire
et je dis aussi pour les républicains ce
sont des partis qui historiquement ont
travaillé sur des projets on a pensé un
certain nombre d'idées et je pense que
ce serait une erreur de de condamner ces
deux ces deux partis politiques voilà
mais je siégeais avec la république en
marche je veux être très constructif
comme j'ai toujours été je sais je sais
que c'est cette expérience-là de savoir
travailler au delà des sensibilités des
clivages politiques est véritablement si
ça peut permettre de faire réussir la
france pour les français
eh bien je pense que c'est une voie
qu'il faut explorer et y travailler tous
ensemble
encore un mot concernant le pays de
montbéliard le pays de montbéliard se
sauve ce matin à deux députés en marche
donc denis sommaire et vous même on a un
sénateur martial bourquin socialiste qui
a été très agressif envers vous comment
vous allez pouvoir travailler avec
quelqu'un comme lui ou d'autres
socialistes d'ailleurs je le dis il faut
effectivement arrêter avec ces ces
querelles entre nous les français
attendent et les populations de ce
territoire qu'est le deuxième territoire
industriel de france
nos populations attendent autre chose de
nous que de ce genre de ce genre de
chamailleries je ne serai jamais là
dedans le paysage du politique du pays
de montbéliard va être modifié d'une
façon considérable effectivement avec
l'élection de denis sommer sommaire j'ai
vraiment l'intention
et il le sait nous avons déjà échangé à
plusieurs reprises ensemble nous avons
l'intention de travailler pour notre
territoire en terme de développement de
diversification de service public pour
les populations
et oui notre travail à tous les deux
nous apporter doivent porter leurs
fruits très rapidement
mais encore une fois je rentre pas dans
ces dans ses querelles j'ai entendu ces
attaques elle me touche parce que
quelque part elles viennent de mon camp
mais je ne je ne
m'arrêterai pas pour autant je vais
continuer sur sur ma bois c'est ce
qu'attendent les électeurs c'est le
message qu'ils ont passés avec le
résultat que j'ai obtenu justement
frédéric barbier rester avec nous la
suite va vous intéresser puisque nous
allons dans la troisième circonscription
du doubs les républicains n'ont pas
réussi à conserver leur siège c'est
denis sommaire vous l'avez dit qui l'a
emporté face à frédéric quartier avec un
score très serré hier soir et jusqu'au
bout c'était la tente et l'incertitude
comme l'ont constaté vanessa hirson et
laurent brocard tout au long de la
soirée
les soutiens de frédéric quartiers sont
sous tension les yeux rivés sur les
écrans d'ordinateur ou sur les réseaux
sociaux chacun scrute des résultats qui
arrivent au compte goutte et ils sont
très serrés si le candidat les
républicains printemps la tête
dans la foulée il perd davantage à face
à son adversaire de la république en
marche
seulement 56 voix les séparent et à
19h30 puis 30 minutes plus tard le
résultat définitif tomber
frédéric quartier candidats les
républicains pair avec seulement 113
voix d'écart donc c'est vous partez sur
une bataille qui était pas simple alors
que jamais debout score quand on perd
mais pour quelqu'un qu'on disait sans
notoriété et sans capacité
je pense qu'on fait un très bon score
devant le qg de campagne de deux
missionnaires celle enthousiasme même si
le candidat de la majorité l'emporté
d'une courte tête
c'est un résultat qui est serré mais
très honnêtement je m'y attendais mme
c'est une circonscription où les
résultats à chaque fois sont assez
serrés je rappelle qu'en 2012
marcel bonnot avait été lui aussi avec
très peu d'écart et joseph parrenin
avant lui avaient été aussi élu avec
très peu d'écart donc je savais que ça
allait jouer à très peu
élu député de la 3e circonscription du
doubs denis sommer prend à la droite ce
territoire tenu depuis 2002 par le
républicain
marcel bonnot alors on a envie
d'entendre les nouveaux députés de la
république en marche parce que on a
entendu des républicains plusieurs de
sensibilité différente on a entendu
cécile untermaier pour le parti
socialiste
finalement vous allez vous n'allez pas
avoir de véritable opposition didier
parisse dans cette nouvelle assemblée
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde est
prêt à faire des concessions
un monde je suis ainsi frappé de de
l'extrême difficulté de certains
candidats vous avez interrogé
aujourd'hui à dire ce qu'ils feront
exactement c'est quand même assez
étrange et quel que soit le bord
politique auquel vous vous êtes adressé
vous avez un axe central lax de la
république en marche
le programme est clair la vision est
claire l'intention est claire
et puis vous avez à côté des gens qui
s'y associeront pas moi ce que je crois
c'est que tout simplement le
gouvernement sera jugé sur ses actes
l'action politique sera jugé sur les
actes moi j'attends tout simplement que
l'action politique des partis
socialistes les républicains que vous
avez interrogé tout alors soit elle
aussi jugé sur des actes à vous vos
premiers dossiers vos premières mesures
on les connaît à l'égal des grands
chantiers d'emmanuel macro mais vous
comme député en bourgogne franche comté
vous aurez en vie à coeur de porter quoi
déjà on a n'a premier un premier schéma
j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure
développement économique et
développement des solidarités qui est
extrêmement forte et extrêmement
puissants notre rôle à nous ça va être
bien sûr de faire en sorte qu' il soit
perçu qu'il soit effectif dans nos
territoires
et si vous mettez boutabout là
du travail si vous mettez boutabout la
suppression des cotisations salariales
sur le chômage et la maladie si vous
mettez des premiers éléments de la
réforme de la retraite
enfin vous avez encore et encore plus si
vous voulez vous avez quand même schéma
traille qui est qui et nos on verra très
vite le positionnement politique des
autres partis sur ces terrains là soit
il considère qu effectivement il ya une
attente très nette des français est nous
semble-t-il elle est là n'oublions pas
quand même l'élection de laquelle nous
venons de sortir enfin série c'est un
quitus qui est donné à une posture
politique c'est pas pour autant un
quitus qui sera donnée à l'avenir verra
très vite tout ça parce que dans le
dernier quinquennat
on se souvient que ont commencé quelque
chose et puis trois ans après en général
c'était toujours pas arrivé alors c'est
le temps législatif effectivement mais
est ce que il vous semble qu'il faut
aller et je pose la question didier
martin beaucoup plus vite que ce qui
s'est passé
tandis qu'emma précédent mais voilà
alors l'histoire des ordonnances a été
débattue dans cette campagne beaucoup
fait comme d'autres dossiers assez
sensibles comme la csg
mais au delà il y a je dirais ya la
vision et comme le disait françois
patriat emmanuel macron ira loin parce
qu'il voit loin et il a conçu et chiffré
son programme avec des économies
incontestable qu'il faut faire avec des
ressources qu'il faut rendre plus juste
plus équitable pour l'ensemble de la
population c'est la réforme qui touche
la cg et puis c'est le choc
psychologique que le monde du travail
doit enfin la prise de conscience avec
des mesures effectivement qui ont un
fort écho on parle de réduction des
charges sociales pour les entreprises
on parle de gains de pouvoir d'achat
pour les plus faibles salaires pour
l'allocation adulte handicapé pour le
minimum vieillesse ligne français lésés
quand le plus tôt possible sur le code
du travail il faut une procédure
accélérée respectueuse malgré tout des
partenaires sociaux puisque ces accords
qui seront signés à matignon dialogue
on va faire réagir jean marie sermier
parce que là j'ai l'impression que vous
buvez du petit lait vous souriez
béatement est-ce que la précipitation la
vitesse ça vous c'est quelque chose qui
vous va mais c'était d'intention mais
c'était toutes les mesures et genève
sont servis à chaud je pense que d'abord
effectivement on est on peut être
d'accord sur la revalorisation du
travail
la valeur travail c'est une de mes
valeurs essentielles je pense qu'on ne
peut être d'accord sur le fait qu'on
redonne du pouvoir d'achat aux français
à condition qu'on n'en prennent pas d'un
autre côté en additionnant de la cg
supplémentaire au niveau fiscal tout ça
c'est important
moi je vous rappelle quand même que dans
tout ce que vous avez cités vous avez
oublié 80% du territoire
on a aujourd'hui et moi je les sur ma
circonscription bien entendu le message
que la ruralité pu faire développer
notre pays que la ruralité peut être un
élément essentiel pour être acteur d'un
rebond au niveau français et je voudrais
me battre mois dans les mesures que vous
avez cités et effectivement on peut
faire un petit bout de chemin ensemble
les me battre pour faire en sorte que
nos communes nos villages nos petites
villes et retrouver un lien dans notre
territoire pour les pâtes ou metropolis
et la france ont dit c'est toute
l'agriculture 15 milliards
d'investissement pour la modernisation
de notre agriculture
c'est un signe très fort le faire le
tout c'est pas de l'annoncer le tout
c'est de le mettre en place maintenant
et d'assurer un truc c'est que quand on
a des groupes parlementaires qui sont
extrêmement importants quelquefois c'est
plus compliqué que ça justement en
parlant d' opposition de ce qu'on a dit
tout à l'heure que même les républicains
sont prêts à vous tendre la main
est ce que votre première opposition ne
va pas se manifester
cet automne dans la rue quand j'entends
parler doit travailler genre de choses
est-ce que c'est pas votre crainte
il faut vraiment souhaité que ce ne soit
pas le cas comment ça peut ne pas l'être
un des idées claires je crois plutôt le
programme avec emi clairement à plat des
battures vue est institué de une
négociation vous avez sur le droit du
train ici c'est le 6 sélections oui
j'avais là 48 réunions qui ont d'ores et
déjà été prévues réunion avec les
organisations patronales les
organisations syndicales 48 le
gouvernement a accepté que même si la
voix de l'est
non c'est en soi une bonne une bonne
voie c'est pas un problème technique
c'est un problème de consensus et
discussions le gouvernement a accepté de
donner un tout petit peu de temps au
temps l'objectif c'est fin septembre
début octobre au plus tard
ça doit permettre et d'avoir une vision
claire et d'appliquer les règles que
nous avons prévu d'appliquer et en
troisième lieu effectivement oncle sinon
a conçu ce sont en tout cas que tient
débat suffisent à en arriver à ce point
l'animateur de cette émission j'aimerais
vous poser une dernière question une
réponse en un amour chacun comme député
de la région en bourgogne franche comté
on a parlé d'agriculture et à l'instant
vous auriez envie de pousser quel projet
de loi particulièrement didier martin je
dirais la formation la formation
professionnelle disparaît tout ce qui
tout ce qui fait la liberté donnée aux
entreprises et à la création de valeur
le développement de la fibre optique
dans tous les villages de bourgogne
franche comté fait trois débats pour la
merci à vous d'avoir participé à cette
émission spéciale je vous rappelle un
tous les résultats les réactions
bfc point france 3 point fr on se
retrouve à 19h pour le 19/20 bonne
journée à tous sur penseront
[Musique]